we recently introduced a vector quantity
called torque a sort of rotational
analog to force and we saw that an
applied torque changes the angular
motion of a rotating body in just the
same way that an applied force changes
the linear motion of a translating body
this week we're going to introduce the
concept of angular momentum which
relates to torque and rotational motion
in the same way that ordinary momentum
relates to force and translational
motion like torque angular momentum is
defined in terms of a cross product or a
vector product specifically the angular
momentum vector L for a point mass is
equal to the cross product R cross P
where R is the position vector measured
from a chosen reference point and P is
the ordinary momentum vector we will
also encounter where third conservation
principle this time for angular momentum
an applied torque causes the angular
momentum to change however if there are
no external torques on a system then the
angular momentum of the system is
conserved or remains constant this is a
powerful tool for solving many problems
one subtlety is that angular momentum
like torque is defined relative to a
specified point so for a given system
the angular momentum with respect to one
point might be conserved
while the angular momentum with respect
to a different point might be changing
often in analyzing a system we must be
careful about our choice of reference
point for torques and angular momentum
in order to take full advantage of the
conservation principle angular momentum
is a particularly subtle and
non-intuitive concept in comparison to
momentum and energy and the resulting
motion is often surprising it is worthy
of particularly careful study